uma thurman also has that kind of
wide-eyed look that chameleon
yeah i don't know why they're attractive
at all um is
she's pretty though yeah see yeah there
you go i found uma thurman
more attractive than i did
there is never a single person that
thinks better than christina
i did it her and kill bill bro i thought
she was hot
bro like andrew get the [ __ ] out of here
you're never back
you're never allowed back on this bike
you're telling me right now that
thurman in five four three two one
what's up everybody welcome to another
episode
of the genius brain podcast
if you've never heard of this podcast
before it's literally about anything and
everything i am your host
david soh and then we have my co-host
for today edric
also known as ed too i almost said that
you don't get it
you know i've been watching dude what
have you seen the um
i've just been watching a lot of
[ __ ] documentaries but one that
really got me
was [ __ ] that britney spears
documentary i i know of it i haven't
watched it yet bro it's
[ __ ] nuts there's so many things i
didn't know about britney spears just
because at a young age i was too busy
jacking off to her real [ __ ] bro
at that time when at the peak of her
popularity whatever i
did not find her attractive i didn't get
it really yeah like everybody you know
when we're in school
everyone's like oh britney spears so hot
so i'm like dude she's not
hot you know what it was it was her sex
appeal though
because she was doing like sexy [ __ ]
we're in the school girl outfit and
everything yeah
dude i nah i just did not find your
attractive and look
bro i was right right because
who looks at brittany now and and says
oh she's so attractive
different that doesn't mean you're right
then she was perfectly fine back in the
day she was so sweet
she was this cute little country bumpkin
oh yeah sweet for sure
i mean like she definitely came off as a
sweet looking girl but
i didn't look at her and like had any
sexual desire
gay boy i swear bro i swear bro like
people would say i'm [ __ ] tripping
you know they're like dude she's so
[ __ ] hot and i'm like nah she's not
hot man
i thought alyssa milano was much harder
listen milano's fine as [ __ ] yeah she
still is hot today i feel like you know
yeah but she wasn't doing the school
girl music video
stuff with water hitting her and [ __ ] i
was hoping i could see through that
shirt so bad
but britney spears was so she was i
didn't know she was also a disney kid
yeah
what the [ __ ] is with all these dudes
gosling britney spears justin
timberlake they're all born out of the
[ __ ] disney camp disney breed stars
bro that's what they've done
what is that mickey mouse club that
people keep talking about what is that
it's just it was just like you know
these uh teenager kids or whatever
yeah it's just a show revolving around
these kids who just talk about [ __ ] or
like you know
yeah it's just scripted [ __ ] that's
[ __ ] yeah it's stupid but hey
it worked wait so justin timberlake was
also a part of that mickey mouse club
yeah oh i mean look at all the stars
that came out of disney though you got
your miley cyruses
you have your uh zendaya miley cyrus has
the ashiest vocal cords i've ever heard
of my life dude
that girl sounds like the kenme mutumbot
she's like this is my new single oh my
yo girl what the [ __ ] happened to your
voice
that [ __ ] sound like you've been
smoking three packs of cigarettes for 20
years yo for real i'm like
what the [ __ ] happened to her voice yeah
her voice is super scratchy dude she
needs like some lotion for them vocal
cords dude yeah
that [ __ ] was nuts because she she was
on the joe rogan podcast and she was
talking i'm like
what 80 year old woman is this but it
was miley cyrus i think she's still in
her 20s
yeah i think so probably like late
twenties or something yeah jesus yeah
and then you had that one dude from ufc
after the fight who shouted out miley
did you see that oh yeah
and then and you know what though
because he did that
uh it got her attention because people
started talking about it
and now they're working on a charity
together oh really yeah so it turned out
to be
you know he shot his shot and he didn't
get maybe what he might have wanted but
still they're
taking on a good cause you know what a
deal breaker is for me for for me and
girls
is the way their voice sounds for sure
if i don't like the way a girl's voice
sounds it's a deal-breaker i agree
it doesn't matter what you look like it
doesn't matter about anything else i
have to listen to that
i can't do it 100 there's been a handful
of times
before where i found the girl attracted
physically and then i hear the voice and
i said
nope that just went
what does it sound like uh it's
different different range of stuff i
find you hot
like monotonous like a robot you know
hello what are you doing
like that type of [ __ ] or or like very
high pitched and shrilling like like
it's super [ __ ] annoying i hate that
[ __ ] hi
oh my god yeah oh that's shut the f
please shut your mouth yeah
shut your mouth but no yeah it's it's
it's a it's a different range of things
it's not one type of voice that i don't
like it's uh
it's different things and so and britney
spears had a very sweet voice
ah her voice is i would categorize as
one of the annoying ones though for
talking voices yes
you know i just like it's like that man
you tripping bro
that was my white trailer trash
snowflake good i loved her dude
she was so sweet but i like i didn't
realize how
much the media was giving her [ __ ]
because
i was super young i was still in
elementary school at the time yeah so
they were giving her [ __ ] about her
being a bad influence to kids they were
basically
i guess in that time it wasn't coined
this but slut-shaming her yeah
yeah the length of her skirts like
parents were going after like
who are you to you know dance like this
and make this type of music for my kids
or whatever what not and she's like this
isn't for your kids
yeah this is my music this is who i am
yeah like she got crucified in the media
bro
yeah even between like the the breakup
after jt and her too
she got the brunt of it let me tell you
something about justin timberlake that
little [ __ ] ramen haired [ __ ]
yeah i mean you know the news has been
coming out after the documentary about
you know he's not that good of a dude
he's a [ __ ] kind of a dick
yeah like he didn't they never hooked up
she they never hooked up at all but on
howard stern
yeah he was like saying yeah yeah like
we [ __ ] or whatever what not
but and he did that whole was it crimea
river which was about her
which till this day i thought it was
because she was a she was a [ __ ]
or she cheated on him she cheated on him
right so that's what i assume
and it wasn't even true i i didn't know
about this but as a young person you're
not really googling or researching this
stuff yeah exactly you kind of just go
with the crowd
yeah and so this whole time i thought
britney spears
cheated on him and broke his [ __ ]
heart because of that music video
which never [ __ ] happened he was just
mad because he couldn't get [ __ ]
he made that video because he couldn't
get [ __ ] what kind of spiteful [ __ ] is
that dude
little [ __ ] robin hair demon [ __ ]
justin timberlake i hate your guts
and and it's no mystery then to see why
she turned out the way she turned out
right i mean
when you're getting that crucified all
the [ __ ] time your boyfriend yeah
media yeah her [ __ ] dad's a piece of
[ __ ] i always say man
it's more surprising that more young
stars don't go crazier
you know or get crazy um
even guys like justin bieber i was like
well
i mean once he started kind of going off
the rails a little bit i was surprised
it took that long for it to happen you
know what i mean
because again man that life is not
meant to be a human being's life to be
like under a magnifying glass constantly
all the time be crucified for any little
thing that you do have people talk about
you all the time
especially at that age you're you're
definitely not mentally equipped to take
that type of person
because even adults now can't take that
type of querism we just talked about
that on the last podcast yeah
yeah not even criticism but adulation
too yeah adoration from that many people
masses of people saying i love you you
got adult women
saying i love you to a 15 year old kid
that's right i want to have your babies
type [ __ ]
how do you deal if i when i'm 50 i'm
thinking when i'm 15
and i got [ __ ] grown ass women coming
up to me saying you know
they want to have my baby i'd be like
yeah
sure yeah
it's crazy how like this whole time i
literally thought in that whole justin
timberlake situation
i truly believed and i think i've told
other people like oh remember that time
when [ __ ] uh
when bernie was being a [ __ ] yeah and
she [ __ ] cheated on and it never
[ __ ] happened yeah
and then on top of that tmz and all
these tabloids the paparazzi
will not give her a [ __ ] break
they're always on her ass even when
she's not popping like that they're
always waiting for her to have a mental
breakdown because that's
kind of what it became bro like she
became such an easy target like you know
but the the when she was dead dating uh
yeah with kevin fetterline too you know
in the post
breakup of that one she just kind of
went off the red shaved her head was
looking like a mess
out in public easy target yeah easy to
because one she's a household name i
guess i don't know if i could say she's
a household name today
but at least during the 2000s like early
to mid
she's definitely a household name and
then so it's easy to get those clicks
easy to get those views by just
say hey look how crazy she is now look
at what what erection and her
her shaving her head too was her idea of
saying like
i'm done with this industry leave me
alone like i'm gonna just shave my head
and the hairstylist too wouldn't shave
her head he would just he or she
wouldn't do it
so she took the clippers herself and
started shaving it and that was her
symbol of saying like hey leave me alone
i'm not this superstar anymore just [ __ ]
it leave me alone
i'm done yeah but it wasn't enough and
there was even a point too where people
were criticizing her about
um she was like trying to run away from
the paparazzi and so she had her kid in
her lap because she just wanted to get
out of there yeah
and then the whole tap is she a fit
mother right you know
she endangered her child it's like [ __ ]
dude i feel so
bad for her she can't catch a [ __ ]
break
she's the one she's trying to flee this
scene because people won't stop
breathing down her [ __ ] neck
and it's not like it's the best it's
paparazzi like these guys are trash like
paparazzi is [ __ ] trash yeah i don't
give a [ __ ] what you say
they're like oh we're just trying to
make a [ __ ] you can make a [ __ ]
living doing something else you piece of
[ __ ]
you know but yeah and she just wanted to
just
i think cause she is from such a small
town too and she
is that country bumpkin she has like
small town vibes to her
so she doesn't know how to deal with
this stuff yeah you know obviously she
was
you know a disney kid and she was kind
of propped up to be a star
but she still has wants of a regular of
a regular small town girl
she wants a family she wants a kid she
wants a quiet life too
but that's the thing about being an
entertainer you don't get to pick and
choose that stuff
but here's the thing though again i
think a lot of it has to do with her
kind of like her name value and um how
much people know her because
you can just as easily talk about people
like roman polanski or like kevin spacey
who are kind of like big names
in the hollywood uh arena but then like
after
all those things that they did came to
light right like roman polanski
i mean this is some dating back to the
[ __ ] 80s and then he left the country
and was living abroad
yet none of it was he he didn't have to
pay the price for anything that he did
but people will
still let him create his art and
continue to let him do it but he was
completely out of the public eye
right guy like kevin spacey too even
louis c.k we just talked about him
after all that [ __ ] came to light okay
how come you're not seeing him in the
headlines all the time and him being out
there
is it because you know he's just that
good
at staying away from all of that does he
have a great publicist
or is it just his name's just not really
worth it to like bring to attention like
that you know what i mean
um but britney on the other hand oh
that's sizzling
you know i mean she had a big resurgence
too because remember
out of nowhere she kind of cleaned
herself up and she looked like the old
britney
that's still not attractive but look at
this guy dude you're a [ __ ] hater bro
i'll tell you something man you tell
that to my 800 faps
when i was like a 10 year old i'm not
saying anything about her as a person
i'm just saying
i didn't personally find her attractive
well okay well from an objective point
of view
we're talking about physically yeah
there's definitely a lot of people who
are
you know just from objectively
physically more attractive yeah yeah
but she has a very special place in my
heart that is britney spears [ __ ]
yeah it's britney [ __ ] yeah and she got
her residency in vegas so she was making
some good money
from 30 million yeah around there yeah
and then there's like this huge part of
that doc too which i didn't [ __ ] know
about once again i'm very distant from a
lot of the celebrity drama type of stuff
but her father has something legally
where
she he is basically the carer of her all
over her money
everything else goes through him oh what
the [ __ ] so she doesn't see a dime or a
scent or anything
so she gets an allowance based on what
her father chooses so
what i don't remember what it's
specifically called and i'll put it into
the video later on
but he has like this legal ownership
basically of her
so whatever moves that she makes
anything that she has to sign legally or
whatever what not
she's isn't like a sole entity it her
father has to do it
so she can't control her own money she
can't control her own life
yeah and so as of right now she's trying
to get out of it here's the problem
though
with that thing that she signed that
kind of gave her father
the the rights over her whole [ __ ]
life yeah once you sign it you can't
petition to come out of it because
you're not considered
a sane person to make that choice so
this is
this only happens when you're obsessed
with somebody who can't take care of
themselves yeah
so when she took that residency in vegas
it's like 50 million dollars it didn't
go to her it went to her dad
and mind you her father was not around
for her he was a piece of [ __ ] yeah he
just popped back in when
exactly and so everybody that was around
her there was somebody that when she was
younger and she was touring around
um her mom had like a uh hired this guy
lady who's kind of like um
i wouldn't say she's more than just a
personal assistant right she was a nanny
kind of like her second mom
and even she mentioned she goes the only
thing that i remember
her father saying was brittany is going
to make me a lot of money
and she goes i'll just leave it at that
that's the only thing i remember
about him when he said anything positive
about freaking scumbag he's a [ __ ]
scumbag
and as of right now he has a control of
her whole [ __ ] life and money
and he won't give it up why would he if
that's his
if that's his intention from the
beginning is just to milk that [ __ ]
cash cow
he's like yeah no you're you're not fit
yeah you can't take care of yourself i'm
gonna take care and he's saying it's for
the benefit of her it's like bro you
were never around for her
now was brittany in the documentary
herself and spoke personally about it or
was this just there have been accounts
well it's
it's stories but it's also excerpts of
her saying this verbally
and there has been written documents of
her saying she doesn't feel safe around
her father
and everything else because she's as of
right now she's trying to fight for it
because britney still has a lot of
hardcore fans and they're actually doing
marches for her or whatever
and she's written down that she doesn't
feel safe around him that she feels like
she's trapped that she can't do anything
and she wants to get out of this but
legally she can't because she's bound to
whatever she wrote
that's a sad sad [ __ ] situation man
to have your own father you know let me
tell you who i like more than brittany
though
christina aguilera dude really god damn
it dude you and you
let me say i don't listen i don't even
like white girls like that but christina
aguilera is mexican
all right she's like she's like 12 2
like 12 8 mexican or something i don't
know what the [ __ ]
one-eighths mexican or some [ __ ] like
she was talented she could sing but i
never found her attractive either
even even when she came back all dirty
and nasty the water scene and stuff and
damn bro yeah maybe you're just like
dick bro
you just might like dick how could you
i've never heard
christina aguilera no no i didn't find
her
genie in a bottle i mean look i like i
said i i respected her talent i thought
she was a good singer
i'm about to look up a deep fake of
christina aguilera you tell me right now
that that's not worth it
[Laughter]
she looked like a sexy dirty johnny depp
in my mind it was a lot better than i
thought she kind of just looks like
johnny depp here
you like that pirates of the caribbean
stuff what happened
maybe my memory's all [ __ ] up what's
going on here you like that one
i didn't know she caught a mer she got
implants
that don't make [ __ ] what they gotta do
with her being hot or not
she she has like the the marilyn monroe
look right here dude nah
bro no she does i mean she's trying to
emulate the marilyn monroe look and she
looked good
dude nah i never i never found her
attractive
okay fine let me give you a scenario
yeah all right you're in your apartment
right now
it's late at night you're a little drunk
this is the first time you drink in
years
you don't know what's going on you see
this photo yeah
of christina aguilera yeah not photos
she is laying in bed like this and you
go
yuck no i'm not saying that i'm not
saying i find her disgusting that's
that's a that's completely extreme jump
there
i'm just saying she is not somebody who
i would typically find
attractive like look at a person like
that and think oh yeah she's right
are you crazy dude she she [ __ ] bad
christina aguilera bad this is like what
eight years ago or something like that i
don't know i mean she's a mother now
you know she got a little miles on her
but she's still a baddie to me
come on man christina man britney spears
i understand you know that's not now
you're agreeing
britney spears her eyes are a little far
apart you know she got that salamander
look to her but but the thing is some
people find that
beautiful to have it's an exotic look
you know a lot of models
exactly uma thurman also has that kind
of wide-eyed look that chameleon yeah i
don't know
um she's pretty though yeah see
yeah there you go i found uma thurman
more attractive
there is never a single person that
thinks better than christina aguilera
her and kill bill bro i thought she was
hot bro
like andrew get the [ __ ] out of here
you're never back you're never allowed
back on this pie
you're telling me right now that um
thurman is more attracted than christina
aguilera during that time i thought so
yeah yes yeah he sheep's a gal are you
[ __ ] kidding me yeah i thought so i
i can't even again at that time kristen
crook
i found her more attractive she's super
cute yeah she is super cute and pretty
you know yeah oh
i got one um um thurman dude who was it
what was her name
china was back to china from wwe
rest in peace i love you
oh [ __ ] that baby choke bro
oh my god saying um is not pretty um is
really pretty
but christina
hey rest in peace man christina aguilera
had curves
and she had vocals she could sing like a
mother oh no she could no no
okay okay here's the thing here's here's
here's the fallacy
in your in your memory right now you
think christina aguilera had curves
look at when she debuted those curves
came later on bro
she didn't have those curves when she
came out she was she was very petite
when she came out
definitely a young um thurman very
pretty dude that's what i'm saying
her and kill bill was she was hot bro
very attractive what was what was the
hot part where she [ __ ] had blood and
everything around her
just her badass character man about
talking about her character i'm talking
about the physical [ __ ] that you jack
off to
how [ __ ] dare you um thurman oh okay
let me tell you this hey you just like
you just she's very pretty she's very
like she looks like she's looking
at her look at her body she was stacked
too bro
um thurman hey check it out and tell me
that i'm tripping
looks like you naked what are you
talking about i thought you should tell
tell me she does not have a nice body
uma thurman body body yeah young uma
thurman body
i can't believe you're having this
conversation with you right now hey but
the dog
you're not going to say i'm wrong i'll
tell you that
oh she had a nice see that's what i'm
saying bro
but what was this i thought dude i'm
telling you bro she's hot man
i'm not tripping man scarlett johansson
hot or not oh for sure
for sure scarlett johansson like i've
been a fan of her
since lost in translation i mean people
who know me know that that's one of my
favorite movies of all time
um that's when i first saw her and i was
like dude she's so pretty you know what
i mean
and then she became hot she went from
pretty to like got hot
i mean come on that infamous red dress
you know what i mean on the red carpet
that was like
that was the peak of of scarlett
johansson not to mention i love her
[ __ ] husky voice
like that that oh you like that i'd like
mike
miley cyrus bro it's there's a there's a
difference between uh
you know miley cyrus and scarlett
johansson i'll show you husky
i'll show you [ __ ] the kemi mutambo
by the cyrus voice
this is like dude his is like super
scratchy he's just like he just sounds
like he's
needs a glass of water yeah he sounds
like he needs to clear his throat
constantly like bro you need to swallow
vaseline you need to smooth
those [ __ ] vocal cords of yours damn
because
before was different huh that's what i'm
dude
that's what i'm saying man no but you
had you
you know what it was bro you had the
[ __ ] teenage think with the small
head vision
you know this is the one that i like
this is the version that i enjoy
okay she's bad as [ __ ] so but that i'm
saying came later on
that came later on fine i'm talking
about uma thurman at her best and
christina aguilera at her best
i still think um thurman looked better
you know that's that's just
hey you saw what um thurman looked like
right now thurman's fine
i think she's really really pretty yeah
but christina aguilera's
look i'm not saying that she's an ugly
person or anything you said that
christina aguilera is ugly and you said
that oh [ __ ] you said that britney
spears
everything that she got is recorded on
this podcast dude
come out of my mouth those two were
iconic they were all it was they were
christina aguilera or britney spears i
will say
i definitely prefer christina aguilera
more than i prefer britney spears yeah
and look man
at the time i caught a lot of flack for
saying that [ __ ] by saying that i didn't
find them attractive it was like
like [ __ ] you know just the worst
thing i could possibly say to say that
oh i don't find them attractive
and it wasn't like i was trying to be
you know all [ __ ] uh different from
whatever but i just looked at him i'm
like dude i don't see why you guys think
they're so [ __ ] hot
like i can understand people find that
look attractive but like to the point
we're like oh my [ __ ] god
they're like the hottest girls in in the
world
i'm like no that is [ __ ] pretty
though hey
even [ __ ] monica bellucci at the time
at that time period was
[ __ ] fire i don't remember what
monica bellucci looks oh bro monica
baluchi even in the matrix days she was
so hot bro well monica bellucci is
different dude she looks like
she's like a a one in the million type
but
that's what i'm saying like did that's
how people were talking about these
britney spears and christina aguilera
like they're not in like the monica
bellucci
hotness right because she's monica
bellucci looks like an artwork
yeah she does yeah she's like she's like
um uh what's her face
[ __ ] blood vile lady angelina jolie
oh
see oh that's a good name yeah angelina
jolie during that period too i thought
she was super fine
okay we're now we're now we're deviating
all right we're talking we're not doing
we are talking about who we were
attractive at the time i'm talking about
pop icon idols in this realm
because clearly just just from an
objective like
just artistic beauty look there's a ton
more monopoly
angelina jolie i found jessica simpson
to be hotter than both those two
simpsons are hotter than both of them
yeah but she has an anus on her face
though so
that's the part that threw me off
jessica citizen was a baddie too she had
that wreck
until until [ __ ] she had the reality
tv show and i found out how dumb she was
and that [ __ ] broke my [ __ ] heart
dude you gotta wonder though like how
much of it was scripted how much of it
was really hurt because
come on man we all know at this point we
didn't know probably at that time but we
all know at this point that so much of
the reality [ __ ] is scripted and it's
like they're playing too
oh there's definitely a lot of scripted
[ __ ] but when she said uh
she couldn't figure out why chicken of
the sea didn't have chicken in it i was
like that's her
that that's a hundred percent her yeah
i'm like you you pretty
man we're just going to leave it at that
yeah that's [ __ ] crazy i can't
believe you're the only person i know
that at that time and at that age didn't
find christina aguilera i did not
britney spears attraction like people
got mad at me because i would say that
[ __ ] you didn't get caught up in the
voodoo
no i did not get it caught up in the
voodoo who would you who would you
compare them to at the time then
in terms of like a music person um
i think at that time well a little
before i guess that time i found aaliyah
hot you know well aaliyah is yeah ely is
something else yeah
i thought i thought she looked really
pretty um and look aaliyah was
also very petite too but she just kind
of hadn't it's like the whole vibe you
know what i mean she had that rubber
band around her waist dude yeah
like that just that confidence and like
she that kind of
low-key mysteriousness that the vibe
that she had
the whole thing was sexy um let me think
who else i mean i can't i can't really
remember who was popping at that missy
elliott
come on doc come on doc
come on dog yo you're kind of cute now
come on bro you want to talk [ __ ] about
me and my tastes right now you just said
you think missy ali is kind of cute
right now man
look hey man that that's not a take away
from her talent bro but
she is definitely not somebody i found
attractive
oh man missy elliot come on bro
come on bro yeah that's it he doesn't
throw that name into the mix right now
oh this is too [ __ ]
funny man no but who who else was who
else was really popular at the time like
that whole brittany era nsync was
popular at that i'm trying to remember
like the the group
that was what early 2000s right yeah
early 2000s
um i think that was at 2 000 actually
the whole y2k period
um there was um
female pop idols i'm looking it up right
now yeah in 2000
stacy oracle who the [ __ ] is that oh
shakira shakira
yeah kyra she was she she was like one
of those well okay
i i found shakira to be attractive but i
thought she's way too crazy
like i was like whoa man that that
energy is like you need to bring it down
a few notches
hey don't you talk [ __ ] about shakira
dude shakira is
undeniably fine as [ __ ] she is she's 40
now she's still fine as [ __ ]
oh jlo j-lo yes she had i mean the fat
ass bro
and and j.lo is still fine as [ __ ] yes
how old is she she's like in her 40s
isn't she oh
i'm sure she's like 50 by now oh is she
yeah maybe maybe like late 40s but yeah
jayla was around that see that's what
i'm saying there's like all these other
people that
jennifer lopez is 51 years old yeah yeah
so you know what kind of [ __ ] person
is 51 who looks like that
a celebrity who has the money to [ __ ]
dude
take care of themselves what the [ __ ]
she looks so good
yeah but that that's also a lot of
makeup too if you look at a lot of these
stars without the makeup yes they do get
all that [ __ ] skin care and botox and
everything to stay
looking rejuvenated and young but then
makeup game is a big she's doing botox
she does it very well
very subtly very nice all of those stars
there's no way bro you could be 50 years
old and not have wrinkles or
like not have that many defined wrinkles
there's just no way that's true
yeah it's just it's father time always
wins well just to let you know i have
zero respect for you now
and then what the [ __ ] you're talking
about bro
you agreed with me on everything
and i love shakira i didn't say i didn't
say anything negative about her i said
she's
not i would lose 40 pounds for shakira
right now and she was like
david oh i want you to lose weight i'll
be like i'd do it
well name another one that was around
around that time there i know there's
more
there's more but j-lo is definitely i
mean she's just
classically hot even as 51. yeah i would
prefer jayla over a majillion people
people
that's what i'm saying bro that my point
exactly man is like there were so many
more
uh stars that i found attractive but
christina aguilera was up there for me
though man she was bad dude
especially the implants but but she was
more cute when she came out like britney
yeah and then she took that you know the
johnny depp
for some reason when i saw that i was
like that's not what i remembered yeah
all right let's get into this right
there
we'll get into the
so on today's genius suggestions right
we're calling them suggestions because
if you call it advice
apparently you get into some legal
trouble oh really yeah i heard about
that
like if you if you give somebody
unsolicited advice and they uh they take
it
something can happen to you so they're
called genius suggestions what
yeah now now [ __ ] even giving advice
can get you in legal trouble
it's like i'm giving you [ __ ]
financial advice or
okay you gotta be careful okay here we
go uh
hey david i would like to stay anonymous
please and i'm so sorry if it's long but
there's a lot that i need help with my
girlfriend of four years and i broke up
due to my time commitment issues and i
still don't know how to make time
nor do i know why she was able to break
up so easily
what do you look like show me a photo
some backstory for context
she and i got together in grade 11 of
high school and attended the same
university
we were in the major we were in the same
major up until winter of last year
i am majoring in biology working a
part-time job and working with seniors
at a senior care facility in my city
oh okay doing sweet okay
my i guess ex now girlfriend is majoring
in computer science
and does not have a job at the moment
interesting gotta bash it a little bit
basically a bum yeah i'm over here
working two jobs and i'll be helping
hearing she only comp sci and she don't
help nobody
we are both from religious conservative
households that aren't open to dating
i am the firstborn of my house and the
only son while she is the youngest of
the house with an
older sister very good context guy what
happened
due to my busy schedule and the workload
of being a full-time biology student
i'm busy most of the week our covered
restrictions made it hard for me to be
able to hang out with my with friends
and ex-girlfriend as often as i used to
when the restrictions were lowered early
fall
i wouldn't be able to hang out as much
because my mom is a two-time cancer
survivor
and falls under the high-risk people's
category damn bro
this guy [ __ ] really stacking himself
to i know you know
when i fell over i stood up for my nine
inch dong that kind of just
that was a tripod because of this my ex
and i would be able to hang out less and
less
this was annoying to her because she
doesn't have friends that she hangs out
with
other than me and the only person she
talks to are guys that have previously
been into her
been into her and she keeps around
because they're chill i know it's weird
and i brought it up to her
but she cried so that's it that's all it
took bro
since i live with my mom dad and little
sister they usually drag me out on the
weekends to drive around and play board
games at home just to keep things normal
in these uncertain times
anyways this problem would present
itself often that i couldn't hang out
with her as much as i used to she would
she would scream and also give me one
word text
or the shrug emoji when i try to talk to
her damn this is how long
let's skip along because of the
heightened restrictions so she said that
uh let's see every time we try to fixing
she'd agree that the solution was okay
at the moment but then come back with it
three weeks wait later say that she
wasn't happy with it
this all culminated to about five days
ago when she blew up on me for the last
time a few days before we had talked
about going out to possibly pick up some
food
and eat it together outside somewhere
the day we broke up was going fine and i
was talking about one day living with
her because i see a future with her she
agreed and said that she loved me
we started talking at night about random
things when the topic of our possible
hangout came up
i let her know that my parents said no
i'm brown and live with my parents they
control my social life oh i
because of the heightened restrictions
and all she said that they were crazy
and too controlling and started to get
angry and bitter
i told her that maybe we can figure it
out an alternative and she says she has
an alternative
but she shouldn't put have to put any
effort into me if i can't
even stand up to my parents i told her
she was acting like a kid and we could
never figure everything out if she'd
tell me
the alternative but she refused she
asked why i couldn't hang and i told her
what our restrictions are
which don't allow people uh which don't
allow people of different households to
meet
she said that i always make her feel
stupid which confused me because those
were the rules
she said she was fed up and brought up
that i that i shouldn't be mad either if
she talks to the guy she likes
which came out of left left field i told
her that attacks are childlike to which
she said
i'm an [ __ ] and said we're done uh
let's go straight to the coin to me it
feels like she was disingenuous about
her love and the way she talked
to me makes it sounds like i was evil
sorry for how long this is again
but i really don't know how to make more
time for someone to explain to them
that when i can't and be when i can when
i can't
get over a four-year relationship that i
saw as a potential high school
sweetheart story
man that's so much to unpack bro number
one
let's talk about this [ __ ] hmm
is that is that a good old high school
college drama that you think is so
complicated at the time but you look
back on it and it's so easy
it's so simple dude it's hard to say
this right just because obviously
like i'm older than you but i've talked
about the story a thousand times on this
podcast but when i first got when i
first had my
ankle holding crying story
[Laughter]
you know we have this idea of what we
think is perfect right
we always if you guys watch that one
movie called 500 days of summer it's
it's such a good depiction
of um childlike love it's where you can
only pick and choose everything that's
right about a relationship that you're
trying to keep together
and you specifically ignore everything
that's wrong right and
but the thing that you're ending with
this email was fascinating because
you're saying to yourself
well how do i learn how to make time for
somebody right
it's like i don't think you had an issue
of making time you two are just very
very different people
yeah you guys have a very very different
uh definition of what quality time is
well priorities are different um
sounds like maturity level is different
uh
viewpoint on life is different like for
him family values like progressing
himself
volunteering those are all things he
values and puts and
invests his time into and energy into
but then for her it's just like me me me
like come on bro like she's the only
friends that she keeps around are guys
that were into her
that should give you a [ __ ] red flag
right there that alone is enough to be
like
nope so let me tell you bro you dodged
the bullet you [ __ ] dodged the bullet
and i know
four years i mean you guys are high
school sweethearts technically and and
you got into college and started dating
whatever so it's it is
a long-term relationship but you're also
young as [ __ ] man
but but also this young girl seems like
and and i want to say that she'll be
like this for a very long time because
i've i've met girls like this
it's the one who digs their [ __ ]
claws yeah the clean kind
exactly so she needs somebody who can
only devote
their time specifically to her the
reason why she has those other guys
around is because she
needs that attention if she's not going
to get it from you she'll make sure she
gets it from somebody else
because my first girlfriend was like
that she was she wanted to hang out with
guys that liked her still because she
was like oh we're still friends
it's because she liked the attention if
i didn't give that attention to her she
got it from somewhere else exactly she
was always feeding for it yeah right
so yeah it's almost like um kind of like
a
indirect slide at you oh percent because
out of nowhere
you guys are talking about you know
spending time with each other and she
goes well
i don't understand why i can't hang out
with these other guys he's like yo where
the [ __ ] did that come from [ __ ]
what are you i thought we're talking
about us right now about
us spending time no but yeah she's she's
clearly
um still childish you know still has a
lot of growing up to do
and um i don't know if her tendencies of
like
being the way she is will ever really
change in terms of like
her being selfish in a relationship
like basically wanting the attention on
her um
and if there's a lot of girls like that
too like there's even guys like that
where they get overly
possessive and guys tend to be a little
more aggressive than that when a girl
does that i feel
it's their constant need of attention
and number one
i'll say this a million times on this
podcast over and over again if this
topic comes up again
don't you ever [ __ ] get with somebody
that doesn't have friends
yeah for sure damn sure don't even make
friends with people who don't have
friends
that's a little different some people
you know they're in best situations but
if you're with a girl who says that she
can't get along with anybody or you're
with the guy that has absolutely no
friends that should be a warning sign
right there
it's a huge warning sign and then you
also have to understand that the type of
responsibility it takes to be with
somebody
like that great example is like i know a
couple that's
doing really well right now they're a
really good couple they
they're super dope but the guy in the
relationship
doesn't really have any personal friends
so whenever she goes out or she does
stuff without him he always feels that
feeling of fomo
he he gets sad he might be a little
moody his
aggression might come out in that's so
unhealthy in like the mood or whatever
right yeah
and on her part too she goes well i
don't understand it's like well number
one
you knew this about him when you got
with him right he doesn't have
any friends and in fact when i went uh
to their wedding
um everybody that was his best men or
groomsmen
were from people that he met through his
girlfriend or his wife now
oh really right so he doesn't where is
his friends from his next 30-something
years of living where were his [ __ ]
friends
he doesn't have any friends his only
friend his best friend his confidant is
his wife
and that's it and so what she was
started to find out too and in their
personal relationship was
she wanted to do stuff that um that
didn't evolve him
right and the funny thing was like we
had like a heart-to-heart and a reality
check for her was
she wanted to go into uh entertainment
and i'm like you can't get into
entertainment if you haven't even had a
discussion with your husband
and she's like well what do you mean and
i'm like well number one you're already
busy enough as it is
you're you're a mother right not saying
that just because you're a parent like
you can't
you can't go into entertainment or
acting or whatever yeah but you're also
not understanding
this other person that's involved with
you right now i was like did you
let's just call him peter i was like did
you call did you add did you tell peter
that you have
ideas of wanting to be an actor actress
and a singer or whatever
and she goes well he's always supportive
of everything i do i was like no no
he's supportive of everything you that
you do that involves him
right this is something that you're
going to do on your own i know for a
fact peter
is the jealous type not where he's
aggressive or mean or anything but
it hurts his feelings he gets sad yeah
he is the jealous type he likes to do
things with you he wants to know where
you're at all the time i'll say let's
say you're an actress right you're going
to be an actress
is he okay with you doing scenes where
you're making out with another guy
is he okay with you coming late from
doing self tapes and auditions
doing acting classes and doing all the
is he always going to be there
because i guarantee you he's not going
to be okay with it because i know him
personally
and you didn't even discuss that with
him and so for her she kind of made a
misstep in
assuming that because everything was
fine they don't argue that much
but she kind of assumed that he was
going to change for her later on
it's like no that's not going to happen
he's somebody that was secure with who
he was
you're his best friend you guys spend
all your guys time together
and that's how he sees life once you
start removing yourself he feels really
[ __ ] uncomfortable because now he
feels left out
he feels unloved he feels unprotected
and he feels unsure
yeah he has he has some [ __ ] to unpack
inside of him that's for damn sure
you know that that's for damn sure that
that that issue
is uh it goes deeper than just their
relationship um
but yeah that that's the thing in a
relationship dynamic
is that there needs to be balance with
things just like
anything else in life right balance is
is always elusive you know you're always
trying to achieve it but it's like
chasing perfection you're never going to
achieve it
every time you think you're close to it
or have it it's it's it's not there
um and so if the balance does not exist
in a relationship especially when it
comes to like
how time is managed and and how much
time gets invested into each other and
to your personal
part of your lives there is gonna be
you know a problem and it's gonna lead
to argument it's gonna lead to
somebody being hap unhappy both people
being unhappy and it sounds like in this
case
they don't value the same things right i
mean he values
community work he values school he
values
his job he values his family time and
then within all of that
he's trying to balance it also by giving
his girlfriend time
and you know we're working with kind of
incomplete information here because we
don't know how much time they were
spending on a daily or weekly basis if
they like talk on the phone every day
whatever
because there are ways to kind of you
know if you don't have enough time in a
day to figure out how to make time
but then it's never going to be enough
for somebody like that
yeah and also too something that's very
important when you when you're looking
for long-term relationships
it's kind of figuring out what what
deal-breakers are for you mm-hmm
because if for you if family is very
important for you and for her it's like
well you need to learn how to stand up
to them because
what's standing up to them is very odd
because he already kind of laid out and
i'm pretty
sure hopefully if he did this for her
like look my mom's a two-time cancer
survivor i
can't risk hanging out with you and
other people and then coming back and
bringing home like that
this is very dangerous for us so i'm
trying to limit it as much as possible
for the time being and obviously that's
hard because this is young love they
want to be around the people that they
that they care about and especially for
her in her case she's somebody that's
very very dependent on the person that
she's with it's not going to work out
you know so at this point are you why
are you i wonder why you're questioning
what can you do to spend more time
these circumstances are weird covet is
weird everybody had to make an
adjustment yep you know and if she's not
down to ride for that
then it is what it is bro yeah again
it's two things
maturity and selfishness she's immature
and she's selfish you know and in a
relationship
like you just said you have to determine
what it is that are deal breakers what
you find to be important
and i feel like in any relationship that
is going to be successful
and i'm not just talking romantic but
just any human relationships in general
it's a two-way street you know you at
the very least at the very least the
give and take has to be balanced
but generally you should have the
mindset of i want to give more than take
right because i love this person i want
to cultivate this relationship i want it
to grow
and i want to do what i can for this
person and if the other person has the
same mindset if i want to give more to
this person than take from this person
you guys are you guys are trying to you
know
really keep each other fulfilled make
each other better
operate as a team and that's that's when
it comes to romantic relationships
that's what it really is about right
it's about being a team
yeah what would you want to be with
somebody that that weaponizes
ex-boyfriends and people that liked her
before
or or uses your family against you yeah
i don't like that yeah that's
that clearly shows that she only thinks
about herself and maybe in time she'll
get a broader perspective on that and
recognize that she was being silly
but if the maturity level there a
maturity level isn't there
to spark that type of thought and spark
that type of um
kind of like i guess self reflection
it's you can't you can't really instill
that in her
you know even if you tell her hey look
at it this way it's not your
responsibility either
yeah it's not it really isn't and so it
just seems like her
capacity to be understanding and to be
selfless
is really not where he needs it to be in
a relationship in a romantic
relationship
and so like i said you dodged a bullet
bro just just be glad that it's done
with
move on you're young man i'm guessing
what he said he's 24 23 something like
he's pretty young yeah
early 20s man it's the [ __ ] i wish i
was [ __ ] 23 24 again man that was
he just be [ __ ] slaying girls that
looked like anybody by christine
aguilera
exactly no britney spears no no here's
the um
but yeah that he you should be glad you
should be glad that you're out of that
situation because
i mean there's i don't know it doesn't
seem like you could provide her what she
needs and
she obviously doesn't have the same
values as you so yeah you know well and
vice versa she's not going to be able to
give what he needs exactly
yeah so it is what it is man you guys
you get kind of caught up in that high
school sweetheart thing right because
you had this vision of what you thought
light was going to be with this
very specific person but you'll find out
especially because you're still in
college
there's a whole world of new people out
there
and it's fantastic i wasted my first
first two years of college on somebody
yeah and i wish i could get that [ __ ]
back
and let me let me tell you a little
something about expectations young buck
you're going to learn expectations
equals disappointment
yeah this is the saddest podcast don't
you ever expect nothing from nobody
exactly god damn it that's why the best
mindset to have is hope for the best but
expect
the worst you know that i mean if you
have if you cover that
this whole spectrum then it's like
whatever happens is a bonus
and that what really can what mindset
can you really have
out of life other than that the only
thing that you're promised when you
enter this world
is that you're gonna die you're gonna
exit it that's the only promise
everything else is a bonus man
but it's hard to internalize that idea
because like you you think
oh i thought i had this relationship
with this person that they would do this
for me
also this guy has never cried over a
breakup in his life
so trust me he's not going to understand
how you feel
i've literally seen this dude tin can
right here man i've seen the guy run
over his foot and this will then flinch
once he doesn't he doesn't [ __ ] care
he doesn't care at all
well kid i hope we helped you out found
out a lot of new things about his hate
for britney spears
even though she's a broken person he's a
hateful human being
i'm not hating on britney i i wish i
wish
she improves herself or continues to
be in a spot where her mental health
improves and she's just in a
happy place with her and her loved ones
her children
not her father obviously because he's a
[ __ ] scumbag but any other people
that she
cherishes and loves i hope they're
they're there for her
and she's able to find the space man
where she can just thrive as a human
being as a person
you know has nothing to do with me not
finding her attractive
you [ __ ] hate her you absolutely hate
her
you can find ed at ed2
and secret society if you guys want to
cop that gear yes sir make sure you
check it out
and then on top of that you could catch
us every thursdays and sundays
and [ __ ] we will see you all
next time oh and if you guys want to
leave more
questions or topics or life advice or
weird stories
weird stories are the best ones and your
device is the best yes
geniusbrainpodcast gmail.com and we'll
see you all next time
peace